[Music]
this is boris berezowski he was the only
child of a factory worker and a nurse
not exactly billionaire material early
on he began importing computer software
and cars back when the soviet union was
still around just regular small time
businessman type stuff but there was one
thing that separated boris from all the
other wannabe billionaires he was close
friends with the chief of staff of
russian president boris yeltsin and that
was all he needed to get himself
appointed as the head of massive russian
businesses like the airline aeroflot the
auto manufacturer after us the oil
company cfnift and a tv channel channel
1 russia
that tv channel would come in very handy
because once putin was running for
president boris used his tv channel to
get himself deeper into putin's good
graces he made fun of putin's rivals on
air and publicized fake reports to make
putin look good putin became president
and it seemed like boris berezovsky had
nowhere to go but up but then out of
nowhere he turned on putin and started
talking trash about the new president's
policies he became a huge critic of
putin no one knows exactly why he
flipped on putin but he did he even said
that capitalist should interfere with
russia's political process
and surprise surprise almost immediately
bearozzoski found himself under
investigation for fraud not long after
berozowski fled to london to live in
exile
the russian government took over his
television assets and years later in
march 2013 he was found dead apparently
by suicide mystery involving two
governments and a russian oligarch the
victim is this man boris berezovsky the
exiled russian tycoon boris berezovsky
has been found dead at his surrey home
according to putin's spokesperson
berozovsky has sent putin a letter
before he died asking for forgiveness
and permission to return to russia
pretty convenient right
putin's number one credit dies by
suicide but not before apologizing for
everything he's done and begging to come
back home a post-mortem exam concluded
that it was indeed suicide but then just
two days later thanks to conflicting
evidence the coroner went back on his
conclusion and left his death as an open
verdict meaning that his death does look
suspicious but there's not enough
evidence to determine if it was a
suicide or if he was suicided
after boris died another oligarch was
quick to take his place roman abramovic
the owner of the chelsea soccer club
after berozowski was sent into exile
roman took over almost all of his
businesses and unlike his predecessor
roman never dared criticized putin and
has served them well today he's worth
over 13 billion dollars while his
predecessor is in exile
being a russian holder guard doesn't
mean you sway putin it doesn't mean you
control the russian government at least
not anymore being a russian other guard
means complete loyalty to poon not
because they believe in their great
leader but because poon has the guns
putin has the soldiers putin has the
assassins and poison one wrong move and
they could be sent to prison lose their
empires get exiled suicided or a
combination of the above
[Music]
traditionally it was only rich people
like russian oligarchs that had access
to the best investment managers to grow
their wealth that didn't sit well with
some smart people so they built titan
titan already manages over 750 million
dollars for more than 50 000 regular
people just like you and me it's the
first direct to consumer investment
platform where your money is actively
managed by an award-winning investment
team accessible for all income levels
not just the ultra wealthy to get
started all you have to do is go to the
link below down the app sign up deposit
as little as 100
and boom you have access to
award-winning investment strategies for
anything from crypto assets to us-based
stocks to international stocks italian
has zero performance fees no lockups a
flat rate advisory fee it's backed by
celebrities like will smith and kevin
durant and with this unique strategy of
identifying a worse species of stocks
called compounders and hanging on tights
it allows them to aim to grow your
investments by 15 annually which would
imply doubling your wealth every five
years net a fees it was even ranked as
the number one robo advisor in 2020 by
us news plus titan isn't just another
etf or mutual fund you always know
exactly where your money is because the
investment team explains every move they
make with real-time video updates all it
takes is a hundred dollars to get
started for access to titan's
award-winning investment strategies head
over to titan.com jake and get your
first three months of expert investment
management for zero fees that's tien.com
jake for 90 days free thanks to titan
for sponsoring this video
[Music]
back before the fall of the soviet union
in 1991 there were very few rich
russians and even the rich guys weren't
exactly that rich but with the fall of
the soviet union suddenly came a chance
to make a lot of money you see in the
soviet union all energy industrial and
financial industries were owned by the
government by the time boris yeltsin
became president of russia that amounted
to 45 000 businesses owned by the states
now with communism technically over
those businesses had to privatize
meaning that the government had to give
up control of those businesses over to
private individuals but there was a
problem back in the day some of the
richest russians belonged to the russian
mob if yeltsin put all those businesses
on the open markets the mob would sweep
everything up and russia's new economy
would be controlled by the mob
so instead they came up with a plan the
russian government would create share
vouchers that would be handed out
equally among the population these share
vouchers could be used to buy a stake in
any business on sale basically a piece
of paper that gave you the option to buy
shares in the company
but yeltsin overlooked one problem most
russians were poor at starving and when
you're poor the last thing you're
thinking about is hmm i should be making
long-term investments no all you're
worried about is getting money now for
your next meal poor russians didn't care
about shares in the company when they
could have money now and that's exactly
what the richer russians offered them
money now in exchange for their share
vouchers so millions of russians sold
their vouchers to a small group of
russian men who used those vouchers to
sweep up all those 45 000 businesses at
fire sale prices many of which would
become billionaires in the process by
the time regular russians figured it out
a group of around 10 men controlled 70
of the country's finances people were
livid they had been tricked not only
were these guys filthy rich now but they
now control the entire economy they
controlled all the businesses that made
everything which gave them a lot of
influence and power over the president
of russia yeltsin these men would become
known as russia's oligarchs and for a
while it looked like their power and
influence was unmatched but then a new
person came into power under very
suspicious circumstances a man named
vladimir putin and he swore to purge the
oligarchy from the kremlin
where the facility was that
on july 28 2000 putin gathered the top
20 oligarchs and made it clear to them
that they had no more political
influence putin would let these
oligarchs keep their companies and their
money but only if they stayed loyal to
him and the people ate it up
putin would be the one to choose who
became rich and who lost everything so
he started putting his friends
high-ranking military officers and key
government officials in charge of all of
russia's biggest businesses one of
putin's picks was akardi ruttenberg
today arkardi is the leader of the
biggest gas pipeline an electrical power
construction company in russia his net
worth is around 3 billion
and he's been the target of sanctions
more than just once just for how close
he is to putin so who is arkady
rottenberg a business graduate a
military leader a minister nope our
cardi is putin's ex-judo coach and
partner their childhood friends
arcardy was handpicked to become a
billionaire just because he was friends
with putin and rumor has it they still
trained to this day with putin in power
the rules of the game had changed no
longer was it the oligarchs telling the
government what to do it was putin
telling them what to do at the point of
a gun
the facility
[Music]
um there we
[Music]
but go oligarch didn't like that and
decided to fight back
boy was that a mistake
[Music]
[Music]
in 2003 mikhail korkowski was russia's
richest man his net worth stood at an
estimated 15 billion dollars mckell was
the head of the yuko's oil company and
was the top oligarch in russia but there
was a problem you see mikhail thought as
the wealthiest man in russia he has some
leverage over putin putin couldn't just
kill or arrest the richest man in the
country right and mikhail didn't really
like all these new rules putin was
forcing the oligarchs to follow so he
thought as top oligarch it was his duty
to stand up and say something big
mistake in february 2003 maquel did
something that no other god had ever
dreamed of doing he took putin on face
to face and in public his main target
government corruption the same
corruption that let putin pick who took
over businesses and who made the most
money
mikhail had poked the bear he had
embarrassed putin in public
foreign
and now he was going to face the
consequences
soon after the meeting mikhail's
business partner was arrested then his
oil companies had a security but mikhail
wouldn't give up instead of respecting
the warning putin was sending him he
just kept speaking out louder and louder
so on october 25th 2003 mikhail
kortekowski was arrested he was
sentenced to nine years in moscow's most
notorious prison motroskaya tishna and
even then he still wouldn't shut up he
kept trying to drum up popular supports
so then he got sent to a labor camp
russia's richest man now worth in the
factory making mittens in less than two
years he lost it all his company his
money his freedom
and by 2013 mckell finally got out today
he lives in exile in switzerland
after mikhail's fall from grace it was
clear that a new unspoken rule emerged
and the message was clear you stay out
of my politics and i won't throw you in
prison destroy your company and take
your wealth and that message stands true
to this day
[Music]
mikhail leeson was a russian media icon
he was also on great terms with vladimir
putin such great terms that he actually
served as his press secretary lisin was
also the founder of russia today or rt a
russian news channel you've probably
seen on youtube he wanted to turn rt
into moscow's version of cnn and for six
years things went great he ran the
network he spread the propaganda he kept
putin happy and he got filthy rich in
the process but then lisa started
getting a little too comfortable he
started enjoying western life a little
too much leeson owned millions of
dollars with the real estate in america
his wife and kids lived and worked in
the us
how could the owner of the russian tv
news network be seen flaunting the
american dream living it up in
california and becoming more and more
westernized worse yeah what if those
western ideals started seeping into
their news network the kremlin decided
that he needed to be toned down a notch
what sort of message would it send if
the guy who's supposed to be telling
people how bad america is suddenly
decides to make america his permanent
home and it didn't help much that the
kremlin started suspecting he was
working with the fbi in 2011 those fears
came true mikhail lisa moved to beverly
hills permanently a little later he
resigned from most of his positions in
russia the kremlin just couldn't look
past it their number one propagandist
had taken it too far so mikhail leeson
was found dead in a washington hotel on
november 5th 2015. at first they said it
was a heart attack then they said
alcohol poisoning a few days later it
was death by blunt force trauma he had
gotten drunk and fallen down
the problem was people kept coming out
with more information the hyoid bone in
lisa's neck was broken an injury not
consistent with a simple fall he was
likely strangled then a little later
another report was released saying that
there was evidence of trauma on his
upper and lower extremities classic
signs of someone who was beaten to death
but it didn't matter the official
verdict was death by accidents
to the other oligarchs it was yet
another warning no matter where you are
in the world don't get too comfortable
then there's vladimir gozinski putin's
most hated oligarch just like everyone
else on the list guzinski made his
billions after the fall of the soviet
union the only difference was he made
his money on his own not from buying out
russian businesses after failing at
almost everything in life including
university and the military guzinski
joined guidas a theater school to make
money he drove a taxi and traded on the
black markets in 1987 with just one
thousand dollars he started the first
state approved women's clothing company
and from there he went nowhere but up
and then thanks to his theater
background he turned his company into a
media corporation called media most he
played his political cards right with
yeltsin and after the president's
re-election he was rewarded the
country's first private tv network ntv
guzinski has always been critical of
yeltsin's governments but he knew when
to suck up and it served him well as
soon as he got his tv network he went
back to criticizing everything yeltsin
did being a weaker leader yeltsin did
nothing to make him stop but then putin
became residents and things started
changing fast
guzzinski had been sympathizing with
putin's opposition so one of putin's
first acts as presidents was to launch
an investigation against kuczynski and
put ntv back under government control
in june 2000 kusinski was arrested on
unrelated charges and jailed in the
infamous biaturka prison this place is
terrifying the president is overcrowded
and overheated and because of this
epidemics in the jail are a huge issue
so officers grew prisoners and cells
according to sickness a cell for
tuberculosis a cell for aids a cell for
users of a specific drug guzenski
definitely didn't fit in he was just a
regular businessman he would have been
eating alive thankfully after public
outcry he was released three days later
into house arrest a few weeks later he
agreed to sell all his media assets for
300 million dollars and left russia
forever he wasn't going to risk another
prison sentence not for all the freedom
of speech in the world
pipeline
[Music]
remember this guy cardi rottenberg
putin's own judo partner who became the
head of the biggest gas pipeline and
electrical power construction company in
russia well his construction company was
responsible for building the north
stream 2 pipeline a pipeline that would
carry natural gas from russia to germany
the pipeline alone cost 11 billion
dollars to construct and even though it
was completed in september 2021
arcardy's company was still waiting for
the 50 share western energy companies
was supposed to pay but then putin
invaded ukraine and the pipeline was
cancelled putin and arcardi were
childhood friends they grew up together
this deal would have made arkady
insanely rich even way richer than he is
right now now come on putin must have
known what would happen to arcadie's
biggest money maker if he invaded
ukraine but putin invaded anyways
without a second thought as to how this
would affect his childhood friend now
arcadia stands to lose billions of
dollars and this really epitomizes the
relationship between russia's oligarchs
and putin no matter how rich how
influential how indispensable they may
think they are they will always be
putin's female dogs
[Music]
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the
video i'm really really happy with how
this one came out if you're new here we
make documentaries just like this one on
money power and crime so if you like
this one you should definitely subscribe
and consider clicking the join button
below for more documentaries just like
this one that are longer and too
controversial to be released to the
public anyways that's going to wrap it
up you can follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io stay dangerous out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you